and welcome everyone uh bear with me for
a moment well I
finish a
last process to get our event started
it'll take me just a couple of seconds
here
and thank you for your patience
and I do want to welcome everyone
to AI for decision making
business strategies and applications
this is an introduction to uh
fairly new online program that Wharton
online offers my name is Stuart Creek
I'm with simply learn simply learn
provides the technology platform for
the online program but here today to
tell you about it is Professor Don
usedman who is director of Wharton
online and
it'll tell you a little bit about him
when we introduce him in a moment
I am going to be asking some questions
about you and the audience periodically
so please be alert for those polls if
you're watching on a streaming service
you can put answers to that or questions
for John in the
chat
but we will Don will be talking about AI
in business
what it means why it's so important why
you need to know about it I've been
talking about what this program offers
to you and
then how the program
prepares you to deal with a future
that Embraces this technology I'll be
talking about the enrollment steps we'll
cover your questions in the Q a and
we'll share with you how to get started
in the program
so I'd like to introduce Don Dr Don
huisman the managing director of Wharton
online and I will let him
speak about himself
thanks Stuart appreciate it thanks to
everybody who joined us today
and the point of the next hour is
actually to help you understand uh if
this program of study in the area of AI
for business is uh for you if this is
the right format for you and
um
my hope is that by the end of the hour
we'll have answered all of your
questions
to make certain that your investment
particularly of your time is appropriate
so I've been at Wharton for a very long
time I
have been
on the faculty as an adjunct since 1985
teaching in the MBA program and the
undergraduate program
and probably about 12 years ago I
inherited uh the warden online
initiative or started it up actually
as we embraced the mooc technology that
was uh coming of age at that time and
since then we've built it into a large
portfolio of courses that we offer that
are primarily uh uh consumed if it's the
right word
asynchronously so it's an on-demand
format for most of what we do but we
have a lot of items that are done
synchronously in order to create a sense
of a cohort and a community of inquiry
that honestly we hope lives on after the
course is done
um without a mass Stewart for the next
slide
so the slide is about ai's evolving role
in business and the key word in that
previous slide is evolving
so one of the distinguishing features of
Wharton Alliance approach to online
programming is that we Embrace topics
that are not settled science
so this isn't a program in how to uh how
to learn how to program an r or how to
use Tableau to create visualizations
or any of a set of topics that I would
think of in the form of settled science
this is about topics that are emergent
and unclear and uncertain and in these
circumstances what we do at work and
Executive Education when we come up on a
topic like this is we summon an inquiry
and we invite to we set a table and we
invite the one side of the table the top
academic minds and top researchers in
the field who study that topic and this
is a second distinguishing
characteristic I think of Wharton
Alliance programs I only am able to
invite tenured full and dissociate
professors from the Wharton School
faculty to join us in these
sessions and to present material to you
and in all cases The Faculty that come
to the table are coming from their
research centers now where they uh on a
daily basis engage with large companies
while companies large and small to
stretch the limits of an emerging new
approach to doing business in this case
many of the faculty come from our Warden
AI for business center which is a fully
funded Research Center here at the
school
so why is this a topic that we bring to
your attention today and why might you
consider
spending uh some of your time and energy
over the next few months uh studying
this at this issue uh as you'll see in
just a moment there's a long history of
using data to inform uh decisions that
affect business in different ways
decisions about marketing and Finance
and Accounting human resource management
and all the different
decisions we all make every day in our
businesses as managers what's new is
that we have
access to new types of data that are
distinguished in a couple of ways from
traditional data that we've had that
drive our business models and it is
through understanding our businesses to
trying to
identify a set of variables that we have
control over and variables that we see
in the environment that we must you know
approach and deal with but to generate
outcomes that we're hoping demonstrates
why our companies or our organizations
have value in the world
but AI is allowing us to do is to look
at these new forms of data that have
been emerging customer data operations
data financial data environmental data
in order to develop actionable insights
so that what that means is that no form
of data analysis
makes sense unless it can be clearly
tied to a specific business decision
that business Executives business
managers people responsible for lines of
business in your company can act on data
scientists and Engineers sometimes are
drawn to uh exploring data just for
data's sake and the data scientists
associations like informs and other
groups have made a point of suggesting
that that is a tendency that it does not
lead to positive outcomes in terms of
investment in data analytics projects by
companies that the place to begin is
with
Insight an effort to develop Insight
from the various forms of new data that
we have access to
so the point then of understanding AI is
to better understand how to collect and
shape the data we have access to to
informing those business decisions and
the type of data that AI is particularly
designed for
um is different from data we've looked
at in the past in the past typically our
business analytics projects have been
driven by structure data in the case for
AI we have a tool that will allow us to
develop insights Based on unformed
unstructured data large stores of data
masses of communications from your
inquiries coming from customers or from
operations details like the type of
analytics we all collect now from from
web pages uh data that we have access to
that's collected by governments by
outside agencies that is
not under control and may come in forms
that doesn't exactly match our own
internal data warehouses so the two con
components of the data that is different
that requires new types of tools like AI
or data that are vast and and new in
that sense and then secondly data
they're unstructured so it's the scale
it sounds structured nature that leads
us to explore additional Tools in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning with that Stuart let me ask you
for the next slide
so this is a slide we developed for
business analytics course that we
launched oh at least 10 years ago and is
context for this current study of AI and
its evolving world uh in business
analytics writ large including
traditional business analytics and
analytics that involves these large new
data stores of unstructured data the
role we envision for the people who
participate in this class is that Center
column of blue boxes which is topped by
the phrase your role
on one side on the left you'll see the
business requirements you can think of
that side of the house as being the
concerns of the c-suite executives that
are in your company or that might be you
if you own your own company
but people who have p l responsibility
people who who must understand
how the organization is competing in a
Marketplace that is
uncertain and
possibly evolving and also people who
are able to articulate uh the the
proposition of the firm as having value
to a particular segment of the market
that is of higher value than any other
option that that segment might see so
understanding business requirements from
that point of view what is our
performance and how do we measure it how
do we forecast uh events in these highly
uncertain times and how do we guide the
decisions that we make on a daily basis
Based on data that emerges on a daily
basis now ultimately caring about
results which might be a key performance
indicators and might be making a budget
it might be growing the business
according to a forecasted trend line but
all of those concerns from the c-suite
sit on one side of what we see as your
role
on the other side are a collection of
technologists that might include data
scientists might include I.T people
include people at this on your company
who handle the relational database
Management systems and manage the data
warehouses
and who have access to all the data it
might be the Accounting Group it might
be the Marketing Group
this is where the data lives your rule
is to connect the two sides of the house
to act as a diplomat or as a translator
speaking to the c-suite to identify
shape and hone business questions that
are important that may be keeping them
up at night how do we go about coming
out of covid-19 are we out of covid-19
is it time to start investing again in
travel and in uh expanding exploring new
approaches to how we optimize our supply
chains what happens if we hit yet
another variance that will require us to
to change quickly so understanding where
we are in our business environment and
making decisions on a daily basis
towards that end
your ability to understand those
concerns the things that keep the bosses
up at night is part of your role as
translator uh with the other part of
your role understanding enough about the
analytical tools and the uh the
resources that are available to the data
scientists to put the two together to
ask the right questions to develop value
propositions that can be tested against
the actual data and to generate insights
that inform decisions
the worst case scenario is that c-suite
level Executives or others who are
making important decisions about the
business be it operational decisions or
hiring decisions investment decisions
that they base those decisions on their
gut
uh our one approach that the Wharton
School always takes uh to the study of
successful business operation is to not
rely on
um smart c-suite Executives making
decisions based on their gut
our highly preferred approach is to make
decisions based on data that's been
understood and that is applied to
alternative options that are on the
table so the weekend make it informed
judgment
choose a course of action that we
believe will have a measurable result in
a particular way that we can track so
that we can identify if we made a
mistake or if we chose correctly and
need to double down on on the investment
decision that we have made to that point
so that's the role here your role is
just that centerpiece this is not a
technical course where we're going to be
teaching you how to program an R this is
of course where we expose you to many
AI tools and techniques uh that the
faculty and the research centers use on
a daily basis but that's not the point
of this class the point of this class is
to prepare you for that critical role
this is the role that we have seen at
Wharton as Central to success in any
analytics initiative in in the companies
that we deal with and similarly both
McKinsey and Tata consultancy that TCI
says have identified
in their work as well this critical role
for a translator to to make certain that
the Investments that are made of time
and money in building out an analytics
capability at a company uh is worthwhile
so that's what we're working on it's a
evolving field of study the the matter
are not settled they won't be settled
when you finish this course so this is
the beginning of an inquiry that we hope
continues after the course is done and
with that steward let me ask you for the
next slide
so we will look at specific examples of
applications of AI that have proven
themselves to be useful with the
companies that we work with today some
of those are in the area sales and
marketing so there are new approaches to
marketing strategies that we will
identify for you and there are new
approaches to becoming more
customer-centric as businesses that AI
makes possible so with that we will be
hoping that you might spot as you go
through the modules of the course uh
different applications that might start
to make up your portfolio of potential
AI projects that you would be exploring
with colleagues with your boss with
others in your organization at the end
of this of this process
similarly we have examples will show for
uh Financial applications specific in
the area of fraud detection identity
identity verification and authentication
and as a final third area of application
will focus bringing together some of the
faculty from our people analytics
Research Center how big data informs
decisions around HR specifically
candidate selection
retention
policies in the promotion and management
issues and various ways to automate some
of those functions to optimize for your
HR decisions so the Hope here is that we
will help you develop a well-rounded
understanding of this emergent field so
that you know what the terms mean what
the applications that have shown
themselves to be successful are some of
the differences between the choices you
have in investing in different kinds of
Ai and machine learning how to spend
money and time and energy around
projects that generate learning that is
either unsupervised or supervised
we expose you to some of the questions
that uh underscore the risks and ethical
considerations that AI brings to the
fore and we help you develop a
governance framework for the role out of
AI in your organization and in a manner
that fits the organization's organic
growth appropriately and that avoids the
many dangers that are associated with a
Reliance on machine learning and AI
which sometimes can result in a
re-informing inherent and implicit bias
in past decisions that have generated
historical data so more about all that
in just a bit let me take get to the
next slide here
so I'm going to turn the microphone over
to Stewart to work the magic to get you
to answer this question
okay and this question again if you're
watching on a streaming service you can
put an answer into the uh
chat box but
this basically is what has stopped you
from up to now from uh enrolling in a
program of this type
taking an executive
education program with this type so
we've given you several possible reasons
you can check off
one two three or four of them
another 10 seconds to finish the answer
you're watching on our WebEx
live
event
that
so over the half of the audience says
that
they don't feel confident that they have
the Practical exposure
in the AI field to apply it in the
workplace
um
then about
a third
each answered they can't find a
comprehensive curriculum that covers all
the things they would need to know to be
confident of that and then
a third find it difficult to program
around their work schedule so
we'll cover
some of that
turn it back over to Dawn
so those answers are suggestive uh to me
that this may be a good program for you
it is flexible in the sense that uh the
most of the material is available on the
demand we do have uh a mix of live
sessions both with the faculty
themselves that we're hoping are highly
interactive with program support staff
that are in many cases alumni associated
with the school who work in the field of
analytics and they can open up their
doors through Virtual Office hours to
engage with you around both getting the
work done for this course so that you
can get your certificate at the end but
also more practically for discussing and
networking and using this as an
opportunity to extend your personal
network with like-minded individuals who
are trying to study this same business
um and so whoops
I think we've lost our spot here we go
uh so it's a
uh
uh the curriculum tries to follow
specific learning paths that are
associated with those practical
applications in uh Finance uh in
operations in HR management uh that I
had mentioned previously there are
online live discussions that supplement
the self-paced learning we have
assignments and quizzes that will help
you try to apply the Frameworks and
constructs and case studies to your own
circumstances
and we're expecting it'll take about
three to five hours per week for you to
set aside to get this work done we do
hope that you take advantage of the
synchronous sessions fully that's a
particularly valuable part of this
course based on our prior surveys we've
had from similarly structured courses so
that's a great opportunity for you to in
particular The Faculty master classes to
engage directly with the top faculty in
this field to top research Minds in this
field
as a store let me ask you for the next
slide
so at the end of it all you'll get the
certificate that looks something like
what we have displayed here
um that is useful for postings your
LinkedIn profile and for sharing on your
resume
for uh for both that next job you might
have in mind and or for demonstrating to
the higher ups in your organization that
you're serious enough about improving
your value to the firm that you have on
your own gone about
familiarizing yourself with this
immersion field of study which you have
worked on practically
to apply to your current job so the
biggest value we can offer to you beyond
an association with the Wharton brand is
improving your position at work by
making better decisions by being in a
position where you understand enough
about these emerging technologies that
you can either make some individual
Acquisitions on your own
or you can stimulate an initiative at
your organization that will have a
demonstrated return on investment
this is because we'll expose you to real
world case studies and we will also
provide for you access to senior Wharton
faculty who are looking forward to being
challenged by your side of the table
since I as I mentioned in at work
Executive Education when we set the
table we invite the top
academic minds and research scientists
to one side of the table on the other
side of the table I'm trying to attract
the top practitioners in the world that
means a selection of the number of
people on this call to come to the table
and to have a discussion across the
table that would generate knowledge that
neither group could create on their own
that's the dream that's the vision
that's what we try to accomplish through
these online programs of study
uh and with that let me take us to the
next slide I think there's another poll
coming up
a couple of words about the word school
so if uh if you're not familiar with the
the school we're the uh first Collegiate
uh business school established in the
1880s uh we are one of the largest
business schools in the world uh in that
we have an undergraduate program an MBA
program Executive MBA program and
doctoral program uh our Executive
Education facilities that are located
both in Philadelphia and San Francisco
and in Beijing see about 13 000
face-to-face participants annually
the online programs of studies we engage
with uh roughly 150 000 uh paid
participants per year and we touch
millions of others with our free format
uh uh Mooks
the Wharton Alumni network is well above
a hundred thousand graduates at this
stage and they're located in every
country in the world uh so uh we're
hoping that you can join a a community
that will uh speak to your industry to
your circumstances and might prove to be
a valuable uh outcome of this course on
its own uh in terms of prerequisites and
eligibility we're not looking for any
prior knowledge in programming or maths
or statistics
it is the case that programming math and
statistics is underneath Ai and we will
expose you to some of those uh examples
and how some of those algorithms are
designed but we won't be expecting you
to craft them yourself so it's really
designed for either c-suite this program
for c-suite executives senior level
managers or consultants in the field who
are attempting to play that translator
role that I told you so much about a
little while ago with that being Stuart
for the next slide
so this are these are the four sort of
the profiles of Learners who have taken
this type of course in the past and
gotten a lot out of it so if you see
yourself in that list uh then this
program is for you as I say there are
other programs in AI they're much more
technically oriented and we can direct
you to those if in fact that's what your
real interest is in so we're hoping to
summon a group of people like this who
can think about the application of AI in
Practical matters to inform decisions at
your company
and with that let me ask Stuart for the
next slide which may be the next poll
and I'll turn this back
indeed it is the next poll and let me
bring that up for you
so we're just uh
getting a feel for the audience of uh
who's here today
and your level of experience
you know that uh some of you may be
uh early in your career
and curious about this area
some of you may be
far along in your career at the senior
executive c-suite level
as I watch the answers come in it's
interesting that
a bimodal distribution we're looking at
uh people at both ends of the spectrum
so let me share that result with you
yeah about 40 of the audience are people
who are are new
um and curious about this area and about
40 percent of our audience are people
who are the very senior level and
I'm curious about how to apply this
to make their businesses run better even
more so
that
so a couple of thoughts on that so the
those of you who answered C or D are
certainly in The Sweet Spot of the
profiles of past participants in this
type of program that Warden online has
done that have been very satisfied and
got a lot out of the program and it
helped them in tangible ways to improve
their careers so mid-career to late
career is more typically the the profile
of the of a participant in a course like
this if your Junior if you're less than
two years in particular what that will
mean is you're going to need to spend a
bit more time
on the c-suite side of that diagram I
showed you so again you're in the middle
you're the translator you're probably
going to need to spend more time with
some of the more senior people in your
organization to tease out the actual
theory of the firm you know the answer
to the question why would a customer
choose our products and services
instead of somebody else's in the market
what's the theory of the firm what's our
what's our value proposition why do we
exist well you know why are you working
at this firm and not a different firm if
you're making uh you know any evaluation
based on your personal choice so I would
encourage you to think about who can you
talk to uh in the in your organization
who can help you uh puzzle that out
so a little bit more work to do but um
as I say it's uh it's doable but uh you
have to make the investment to get to
get the right learning out of the out of
the program
and with that let me uh
and I think Stuart you're going to walk
us through this part or shall I
God I can walk you through uh I'll walk
you through this but I would like you to
comment
um where I
where you feel elaboration is needed so
okay this program is designed in a
step-by-step program
form
that will start with the foundations
that give you an orientation to AI
through big data to machine learning and
the Technologies
um but in in a form that you understand
what they're used for Rather
God said I'm not going to teach you our
programming
um but we want you to understand what
the capabilities of the Technologies are
so that when we go to the next modules
you'll be able to relate those
capabilities
to
the specific business area that's going
to be covered so in the following
modules we'll take you through the
specific
business areas as exemplars of how this
technology can be applied in business
the first is Marketing sales and
marketing using AI to understand your
customer to understand the channels by
which you communicate to the customer to
understand
um
how to Target
efficiently how to extract intelligence
from your customers Behavior so that you
can refine your sales and marketing
approaches all of those things relate
uh how AI can be applied in sales
marketing world so
um it's very interesting just as an
anecdote uh one of the news stories that
came out of the pandemic fairly early on
was about the
Chief Information officer and chief
marketing officers from
Wendy's fast food chain which you
wouldn't think of as
the technology Powerhouse I think that
they're in the
business of selling people hamburgers
and french fries and that's true but one
of the things they realized early in the
pandemic was
when they went to a non-contact business
model and started taking orders
digitally they had a new wealth of data
about customer Behavior so
they learned that they could tap into
this data and this is the type of thing
where this first module about AI in the
marketing world will help you understand
how companies do that type of thing and
where the opportunities May lie for you
then we'll move on to the AI and the
finance domain again
spoken with a number of companies that
use AI as their entire business model
for example microfinance is a
big area of
[Music]
digital Finance applications on the
mobile phone that allow you to say I'd
like to make this purchase I need
instant credit and as the credit uh
company making a decision about whether
to grant you that purchase
that's entirely AI based on terms of
understanding your personal history not
just from your credit score but from all
of the information about your payment
and purchasing habits
so
this type of
thing is an example of how AI applies in
the finance domain it also applies in
understanding Corporate Finance issues
when and where to to seek
financing for your Enterprise so all of
these types of questions and
opportunities become part of this module
certainly of interest to CFOs but also
to other Executives who need to
understand how money flows through the
organization the next module is
AI for Human Resource Management
we all understand now that
if we're in the job market and submit a
resume to a job board for example the
first step is the resume gets evaluated
by an AI bot that checks for certain
things that the employer wants to see in
a candidate
um
but that's just the tip of the iceberg
in terms of the potential applications
for AI and human resources in
understanding current performance how to
develop your employees
um
human
resource allocation and requirements so
all of those factors become part of this
module and then
the economics and government of AI
driven transformation
what will AI do to your business how
will that impact your business in the
regulatory environment but also in
uh the ethical world that we live in
where
your reputation is driven by how
consumers in the public perceive you and
the issues about the real world impacts
of AI on fairness on equity on diversity
um on
sustainability and also
other impacts that have to do with
regulatory and reputational
[Music]
impacts of AI so
this takes you through these different
areas
not as a be-all end-all but also as a
way to get you thinking about
how AI can be applied in other areas of
your business if I described that
correctly then yes I think so and one
other thing I might add to it is the
notion that we are we're trying to make
you finish one course before you go on
to the next rather than have people
jumping around in part that's to craft
the sense of a cohort like we all
experienced back in the days when we
were in a classroom together so we will
kind of guide you through the
foundations first and then these
different application areas I might
throw in another example in the finance
domain that I know some of the faculty
associated with the program have been
working on which is the uh what we refer
to as the search for the hidden Prime
it's what Stuart was referring to when
he said that some people might not have
traditional ways of gaining access to
credit uh or at least to uh you know an
interest rate for uh for a loan that's
based on a prime rate and that's because
they don't have a FICO score what we
would call the North America FICO score
which is to say proof of your credit
worthiness based on
you know responsibly handling credit
previously so we know that in North
America for example 40 of the households
never really made it out of the Great
Recession and don't have the ability to
generate a FICO score that would get
them the kind of reasonably uh priced
loan to start a small business or to buy
a truck or do you know even you know to
secure a home loan so
um but many of those 40 of the
households are in fact credit worthy
based on other data and so many
organizations uh have built fintech
applications that uh use AI to look at
various transaction processes that you
give as a as a customer there you give
access to give your permission for them
to take a look at your other purchasing
behavior and that's the AI algorithms
that identify what kinds of behaviors
suggest credit worthiness by virtue of
it's learning over time
which particular a mix of uh of
variables in your purchasing Behavior
are accurate predictors of
creditworthiness in the future and that
Aquarius improves over time uh so many
examples of that type will be exposed in
those three sort of application areas
the last AI driven transformation
module will look more specifically at
some of the issues associated with
governance of AI projects and about
handling personal information as well
and uh more practically to the
development of a portfolio of VI
projects as your company to build a
capability given again the fact that
this is an emergent technology changing
every day
and the one thing that you notice on the
slide about electives uh electives at no
cost addition to you are um are the
master classes with Wharton faculty that
will be scheduled throughout the course
so that you'll you'll see who you can
take a lecture from and when it's
scheduled and that's at your discretion
if you want to devote the time do it and
we of course highly recommend that you
do because that's a great additional
value the program provides to you and
again at the end of it um
your completion is documented with the
certificate so
that'll move to the next slide and let
Don speak about
his personal tribe uh
yeah I do know all these people actually
I've been I've been awarded SSA since
1985 so I know all these folks uh even
the youngsters like Michael Roberts and
Matthew Bibble who are now of course in
their 40s and 50s and
but at any rate we have a collection of
uh of uh research scientists represented
here from multiple academic departments
at the school so the school is organized
into 10 academic departments so
operations information and decisions is
the name of a department that kartiko
salavar is a full professor in uh that
looks at uh at operations and looks
specifically about uh decision making as
informed by data in Karthik is the
faculty director of our AI for business
Research Center here Lynn Wu associate
professor of operations information
decisions is also a researcher at cartex
Center Sunny Tom Bay associate professor
of oiad as well and is
actively involved in the MBA program and
in the
organized courses of study around AI we
present for our in person MBA students
Kevin warbach is a professor of legal
studies and business ethics he's been
involved at the federal level with the
uh the use of uh well with the interests
of regulatory agencies and supervising
the implementation of personal privacy
restrictions and in other efforts to
secure personal data and prevent
identity theft at the federal level now
Peter Capelli is probably one of the
most famous
professors of management in the world
has been around a long time it runs our
human resources Center and has been
particularly making a study of the
impact of covid-19 and the changes that
are happening in the nature of work
Michael Roberts professor of Finance
one of the top scientists in the in the
field of
finance and the editor or the most
senior academic Journal Matthew Bidwell
is a faculty director of our people
analytics initiative
and Raghu Iron Guard is a professor of
marketing and also a member of the
research staff on our customer analytics
initiative which is another Research
Center so a bunch of different
perspectives uh and a bunch of different
research agendas that they're bringing
to the table
uh let me ask stored for the next slide
and I think this is for Stuart to run
for a poll
indeed it is and
it's a pretty straightforward question
so
shouldn't take you too long to answer
but based on what you have heard so far
and what Donna shared with you are you
interested in enrolling in this program
let's give you another 10 seconds or so
to get your answers in
close the pole in five seconds
and so it's encouraging 86 percent of
the audience said yes they are
interested in
AI for decision making in enrolling in
the program and that is an opportune
time for us to share how you do that
so I'll go over with you the enrollment
steps
so it's a three-step process to get
enrolled it's very straightforward you
uh email us here at simply learn
act as the intermediary with Wharton and
you send that to ask us at
simplylearn.net
um
the information gets reviewed we make
sure that you have
the aptitude for
Learning and the interest this is not a
strict as you saw the requirements don't
require any
particular technology experience but we
do want to make sure that this is
something that you're going to get value
out of
rather than just something to add to a
collection of certificates
so once we've done the review you'll get
an admission letter the cost of the
program in the U.S is 2 499 dollars
which can be financed at 220 a month
and uh
India is one lock thirty five thousand
rupee uh
which can be financed as low as 44.82 a
month
um
you'll have to check our website for
rest of world pricing but it is
available
uh
nearly every country around the world
um what I'm going to do
at this moment is I'm going to put into
the chat
uh the link to the program page so you
can
check out the syllabus contact us
also including this the
email address that you see there so take
a look in your chat box now
see those links
and
I do want to remind folks that if you
are employed
you can ask your employer about tuition
reimbursement for programs with this
type
which
May either cause them to up front
Finance
program or reimburse you once you've
completed but that's that's based on
your employer's policies not something
that we can offer
um did have a question about discounts
generally speaking
um our assistance is limited to the no
cost financing that you see here but you
can also always contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net to inquire about the
final course cost in your location
with that
like to move on to question and answers
we don't need to stare at the slide
while we're doing that
and uh we have a number of questions
that have come in Don
yeah I've been uh reading through the
chat here and I noticed some back and
forth around the topic of what's the
difference between a business model and
a business plan which is actually an
interesting question yeah I was going to
ask you that one Carter messed that one
yeah uh and government the answer is I
think that the business a business model
is really a collection of three
different types of Statistics
that tries to describe what's happening
for a given company in a given industry
in a given environment so it begins with
an empirical look at the sort of
descriptive statistics what do we see is
going on right now and how can we map
that out as a set of variables so we're
going to try to get to a quantitative
description of your company in your
industry in your environment and we're
trying to tease out from that
quantitative model
the items that you actually have direct
a control over and then we're trying to
tease out as well the relationships
between the variables you have control
over and environmental variables you
don't have control
to to basically forecast or predict an
outcome so moving from descriptive
statistics to forecasting means that we
then are getting into predictive
statistics what can we see in the data
stores that we have from the past that
might help us understand a forecast for
the future what's the trends that are
happening either in a market or an
environment that we can measure over
time and how can we then watch decisions
we might make
change the outcomes at the end of the
forecast
to something that's more optimal for us
be that a growth and market share recent
profitability or if you're in a
non-profit that might mean metrics
around customer satisfaction or you know
decline in the poverty rates in a given
area so this applies these techniques
and analytical Frameworks apply equally
to for-profit and non-profit settings
But ultimately that model is uh
is a kind of a working and growing and
evolving description of your business uh
your uh done business plan is your uh
set of strategies and
um investments in organizational
capabilities that's going to help you
get to those optimized outcomes that
you're seeking I hope that makes some
sense uh it's a long topic we actually
have a whole class on on doing business
models but
excellent
um
asks if uh
result of the program includes uh access
to the Wharton Alumni network
uh it does include uh
access to people who have completed the
program before you and it you have also
access to uh to our general uh LinkedIn
group that represents people who've
completed any work and online course
um so the Wharton Alumni network itself
is also self-regulated and
self-maintained and the school has to of
course live by the dictates of the gdpr
in Europe that's the general data
privacy restriction protocol that the
European Union forces all companies to
adopt and for as a practical matter
we've adopted that same set of
restrictions globally so what that means
practically for you is we would
encourage you on day one of the course
to the extent that you're comfortable
sharing your profile information with
other people in the class we can't just
distribute it and we can't put you into
a LinkedIn group that we generate you
have to opt in so
um
in that regard uh what's happening
online is probably the most important
way to reach into the Wharton Alumni
network
this course does not confer alumni
status you know the vice dean of the MBA
program would have my head if I told you
that that was the case because normally
it costs you two years and you know
three hundred thousand dollars to get an
alumni status from the Wharton School so
I can't offer you that but I can't offer
you access to like-minded people who
have chosen the same field of study as I
mentioned previously the general
demographic of people that we designed
for it wasn't online are people who are
not early in their career where um you
know sometimes maybe the a degree makes
a big difference so someone who's just
starting out we normally build programs
for people who are mid-career to late
career so in that regard we think of
this in the spirit of lifelong learning
and the again the Great Value here is
less in the in the certification and
much more in the Practical know-how it
goes into
um helping lead a successful project at
your company or at least taking around
the work you're doing in this course to
show to your uh to people who are higher
up in the hierarchy what you're thinking
about that check your reasoning and
thinking and in the process demonstrate
that you're no dummy you've been
engaging with the Wharton School to try
to figure out better ways to run the
business you got hired to work in and
those that may be way more valuable than
any uh any uh diploma that you can put
on a LinkedIn profile
um we had a couple of questions about uh
data science and its relationship to Ai
and machine learning
um if you'd like I can take that oh yeah
take a shot okay so data science is the
the general description of the field of
uh how
data is collected processed analyzed
um and used to create information
data itself
contains information but it isn't
informationable form
machine learning and AI are both
techniques used take data and convert it
into insights information
sometimes recommendations often
predictions that's one of the main
values of it
AI being
the field of helping machine systems
make the decisions in a way that
simulates human decision making
machine learning being the technology
that lets genes take data
and from that data you make ever
improving and ever refined insights into
Data so one of the aspects of machine
learning programs is the more data you
give them the more examples you give
them uh the better they become at making
predictions and
ultimately helping you
make decisions based on data that's
available to you we had a question about
deep learning and deep learning is
taking that to a different level where
different Technologies of of artificial
intelligence can be combined
to
better emulate human thinking and
decision making so
um some problems get solved with very
simple machine learning
techniques
some problems require a much deeper
level of
analysis of
combining of different techniques so
one of the important things about this
program is it helps you kind of
distinguish between the different
classes of problems and where you would
want to apply that
anything you want to add to that
[Music]
yeah the the uh I might just highlight
again that this is an emergent field so
the topic area of AI for business
encapsulates a whole variety of of
specific practical applications so for
example we'll talk in the course about
natural language processing which is an
AI application for taking
um a language that we might find in
let's say a database of recorded
messages from your customer base
complaining about stuff and the natural
language processor can both convert that
voice into into text that can be mined
but also do some sentiment analysis to
identify you know segments of the of the
people who provided that those messages
who might be varying versus others who
are not angry who are possibly
curious or or might be the suggestive of
people who are ready for the next
contact so there are various ways in
which algorithms can explore a large
data set both to manipulate the data and
as in the form of natural language
processing but to the point of driving a
decision like who do we choose to reach
out to it's in our knowledge base where
we can convert someone who is possibly
close to being a promoter to actually
being an active promoter for our
products and services in the marketplace
just one example there are many
recommendation engines we all run across
every day as we choose our video
streaming service of choice and the
streaming service says well you know
people like you uh generally have really
enjoyed this upcoming uh release uh
would you like to click on that so
recommendation onions is another kind of
specific application abstracting
underneath it the uh you know the
faculty will be able to help you see how
that classical statistics classical
decision trees
algorithms that we've been working on
for years around optimization and
simulation are are the nuts and bolts of
wood build an engine that openly becomes
deep learning
um Luke who is a CEO and founder of his
company asked if he should be hiring for
the role of
AI
Guru so to speak in his company
I'll say this much Lucas it's definitely
the case that an AI initiative uh is a
team is requires a team that basically
you can't do this yourself so if you
have let's say a small consulting
company
um and you know you have you got you
know your your brother is the IT guy and
you're doing the uh the work as a CEO to
both establish a uh a presence in the
marketplace and and do the business
development
um you know you're probably uh not set
up to do a new life project you're going
to need more for them you're going to
need
um you're going to need a team of people
and in the critical role in that team is
the one we're trying to describe here
which is that role of translator so it's
very handy that you are a CEO because
you'll you know
uh the kinds of concerns and issues that
keep CEOs up at night and you know you
will know it in the context of your own
uh positioning of your company in the
marketplace so you've got a big part of
the job done
um the only other part of the job now is
to understand uh where the data is you
have access to or where you can acquire
it so it may be useful for you to take
the course and then later determine if
you need to hire someone or if you need
to engage with consultant
I've got a question from Ilia in our
LinkedIn audience and then I want to
make apologize if I am not getting the
intent of the question correct
um my understanding of the question is
how does a course like this help you
understand
things like organism organizing uh cyber
security or physical security for a
company
uh well there are courses that are
directly on that topic that I would
suggest you take a look at we we have
one in person here in the Philadelphia
campus we do through the Asis group but
uh I think
uh it's an application area where the
Frameworks uh would apply I'm trying to
think through if any of the faculty
who are teaching in the course address
specifically information security we do
look at um at fraud detection so that's
a matter of one of the cases looks at
how AI can help in real time in an
actual transaction identify a pattern of
behavior that suggests that we're seeing
trans credit card fraud happening uh and
you can interrupt that transaction until
something gets resolved so there is a
case of that sort but as I say I think
you can find a course that's right on
the money if you're in the information
security field
um
Tom in the LinkedIn audience asks the
general question which is what is the
scope of AI for business management
which I think
pretty much the scope of this this
course and we've been talking about but
um
did you want to add anything additional
done to kind of
round round out or fill in any gaps
well you know one thing I can say and I
realized too I'm we're keeping people
over time here so I appreciate everybody
who came if you need to drop off feel
free
but just to give you an example so the
first serious uh uh use I think of big
data to inform let's say the hiring
decision processes at large
organizations to my knowledge was done
by the Canadian hockey league so this
was the or the sort of the origin of the
Money Ball story from the Oakland
baseball team here in the United States
but
people discovered by collecting more
data than they normally would to inform
a hiring decision based on uh high
school or college sports
activity that some players and I'm not a
big hockey fan so I may be getting this
wrong but you know we can tell if you
scored right we have we have records of
that we can tell in some cases if you uh
took an attempt to score if you took a
shot on score but uh it may be the case
that actually the attempts are a better
predictor of future success than the
scores themselves uh and the real story
is probably that possession is an even
better predictor of future success and
an algorithm that combines and wait
scores for those three measures plus
another hundred are probably better in
aggregate at predicting future success
as a hockey player as anybody else so
that's sort of that's where it started
it's been slowly kind of emerging into
marketing and people management uh the
understanding of the stickiness of a web
page so it's been it's practical
applications that walked through
different uh departments in a business
uh and though that's going on that's not
it's you know as I say it it's an
emergent field which is part of the
excitement of it is if you craft a
community inquiry that's growing out of
either your business or your industry or
your part of the world or your areas of
concern uh well it would be uh very
useful for you to keep that group going
after this course is done because the
we're going to learn a lot more about
these things next year than we learned
this year and more the year after that
so it's going to continue and what we're
giving you here is a framework and a
basis for building that Community
as the as the years roll out
okay
um as you said we're getting over time
so I just wanted to cover
uh
I think there was one last question if I
can take a look on my list
I just want to mention how much
knowledge is required for coding because
we had a couple of people asking about
whether they needed to get into the
maths and cutting for
you won't need the code at all in any of
the models that we give you will be
provided directly so you don't need
access to data uh you don't need access
to uh prior experience in any coding uh
it you know it's the mathematical
relationships are useful to know about
so it could be that uh brushing up a
little bit and understanding something
like regression uh would not hurt but
it's certainly not required uh again
it's the normal story about these things
is you get as much out of it as you put
in so the extent to which you can try to
apply it that's the most important job
one if you go to take it the next step
and say well here's you know a
ordinarily squares regression that I
might be able to use in my organization
that would help me understand what
factors actually predict attrition
Etc and then that's going beyond the
requirements of the course but certainly
could be very very useful
if you're technically oriented and want
to take courses in the technology and
the programming skills of data science
and AI simply learn offers those more
likely you would be
learning about what roles of that type
you want to fill in your organization
and referring
some of your employees to those kinds of
courses but you can always contact us
about that as well the focus of this
program is on
how do you understand the impact of this
emerging technology on your business and
the opportunities and challenges yeah so
with that I want to thank everybody for
their questions I hope we got to most of
them I apologize for any ones that we
missed we had a general question about a
certificate of attendance for this
session we don't usually issue those for
program previews of this type simply
learn offers other educational webinars
on different topics and for those who do
get a proof of attendance certificate
but uh not for this session today I do
want to remind everyone in the chat
there was the
um
link
I will repost it to the course page
and our
email address so that you can contact us
I want to thank Don very very much for
um
being with us today I want to ask one
final question of our audience before we
go
that is if you
feel this is a something that's going to
help you
and you want to get enrolled in it when
do you feel you want to start
and we always say
if this is something that's going to
impact your career your business your
life in a positive way
doing it sooner than later is always a
good idea
a few more seconds to answer this
uh to
10 more seconds
okay and here's the result
so uh about a third of the audience is
looking to do this immediately or within
the next three months which is fairly
immediate
um and about half of you are looking to
do this sometime in the future six
months or more out
we'll be here available to you when you
make that choice but if you aren't ready
to do this immediately we do recommend
you contact us ask us at simplylearn.net
we'll be able to answer your questions
um help you get enrolled if that's the
choice you want to make and again
thank you to Don
and to everyone who attended today
really appreciate your being here
I appreciate it too and uh thanks door
for all your help hope to see you all in
class
okay
and that concludes our webinar for today